[Musica]
buonasera mi chiamo rossano ercolini
sono un maestro elementare e mi posso
semplicemente definire un cittadino
attivo tanto ero giovane era un po
agitato conflittuale nel tempo ha
imparato ad essere propositivo positivo
senza però mai rinunciare al pensiero
critico
infatti io sono molto preoccupato per la
crisi ambientale globale che ci riguarda
da vicino
se noi consumassimo come fanno gli
americani degli stati uniti
avremo bisogno di quattro pianeti beh
noi europei potremmo anche ritenerci
culla di saggezza filosofia tedesca la
rivoluzione francese
sì ma da quando esiste la scienza
dell'impronta ecologica che trasforma in
grandezze numeriche il tempo necessario
per rimpiazzare le risorse che
preleviamo dal pianeta ci stiamo
accorgendo che anche noi europei andando
avanti così avremo bisogno di soli tre
pianeti e tutto questo mentre cina india
indonesia brasile stanno copiando il
nostro modello usa e getta
qualcosa deve cambiare e da dove partire
da ciò che ci ha caratterizzato più
steve stupidamente la definizione dei
rifiuti i rifiuti rifiuti sono un
problema i rifiuti ci passano dalle
nostre mani
ecco partire dai cosiddetti benedetti
rifiuti perché ciò ci fa percepire di
essere parte del problema ma se noi
percepiamo di essere parte del problema
è inevitabile che possiamo e dobbiamo
anche percepirne la possibilità di
diventare parte della soluzione allora i
rifiuti
ma esistono questi rifiuti oppure per
anni anni ci siamo comportati come lo
sciocco che indicando la foresta guarda
il suo dito i rifiuti esistono se
mischio la frazione organica con il
resto
allora certo che rifiuti esistono ma se
queste dieci dita queste due mani
tengono separata la frazione organica
d'arresto non ci sono i rifiuti ma ci
sono preziosi materiali metalli
materiale cellulosico polimeri plastici
vetro tessuti legno preziosissima
sostanza organica da restituire ai suoli
in via di desertificazione per pensare
il carbonio al terreno
ecco che allora occorre guardare con
altri occhi
il cassonetto se io apro il cassonetto
con questa visione
io vi vedo un'autentica miniera urbana e
se guardo intorno
nelle nostre città le individuo come
giacimenti urbani da cui estrarre
ricchezza ecologica ricchezza economica
e posti di lavoro
pensiamo ai mobili dismessi
pensiamo ai nostri dispositivi elettrici
elettronici pensiamo ai nostri computer
e ai nostri iphone portandoli nei centri
di riparazione riuso restituendoli
attraverso processi molto elementari di
ricondizionamento una seconda vita dando
loro una resurrezione
abbiamo ricchezza che si riversa sui
territori locali in termini di posti di
lavoro e se non riusciamo a recuperare
il prodotto in quanto tale
dobbiamo recuperare i materiali i
metalli preziosi
l'alluminio loro rosso del rame
l'argento l'oro e le famigerate
terre rare oggi senza terre rare non
andiamo da nessuna parte
ecco che allora rifiuti zero il progetto
rifiuti zero dischiude un mondo leber
liberaenergie apre nuovi settori di
conoscenze collettive dal basso
nel momento in cui tutti gli analisti si
avvertono della scarsità delle materie
prime l'aru material scarcity ecco che
rifiuti zero ci introduce al percorso
dell'economia circolare ed ecco che
rifiuti zero può essere a portata di
mano basta percorrere dieci passi il
primo primo passo estremamente
importante
occorre investire sulle comunità
informandole ben formandole ben
organizzato infatti sono le comunità che
fanno la differenza è la differenziata
se io investo nella tecnologia di ultima
generazione le macchine manche con gli
oil termovalorizzatori creati tale
public relation ben pagate
io spenderò il 95 per cento dei soldi
sottratti alla nostra dalla nostra
bolletta rifiuti per investirli in
macchine obiettivamente inquinanti ma
soprattutto riproporrò un sistema
lineare di spreco e di insostenibilità
le raccolte differenziate vincenti sono
quelli porta a porta e integrate con
isole ecologiche di prossimità
occorrono poi impianti piattaforme per
il compostaggio per il riciclo il
compostaggio è più importante del
riciclo il passo numero 5 è quello di
costruire centri sistemi di centri in
termini di villaggi della riparazione
riuso possibilmente posti a fronte delle
isole ecologiche perché perché se io
devo conferire un frigorifero dismesso
padoin isola ecologica e se io trovo
qualcuno che con occhio esperto mi dice
che lo può facilmente riparare
restituendo una seconda chance a quel
prodotto
io credo di aver fatto un'operazione
microscopica ma di un microscopio che
sommato ad altri microscopi che azioni
porta un risultato
apro scopico il passo numero 6 un passo
di equità se io mi impegno nel ridurre
nella gérard e i rifiuti indifferenziati
del sacco grigio dovrò pagare di meno il
settimo passo ci dice che dobbiamo
investire piccole iniziative di
riduzione dei rifiuti ridurre è molto
più importante nel pur virtuoso
riciclare le casette dell'acqua e l'apt
alla spina e pannolini lavabili le feste
gli eventi le corse non competitive dove
si bandisce la plastica di stoviglie usa
e getta rimpiazzando le magari con bio
plastica oppure con cellulosa o meglio
ancora con i piatti con i piatti
tradizionali
ecco in questo modo con queste sette
primi passi
io arrivo a risolvere fino all'ottanta
ed oltre per cento del problema dei
rifiuti solidi urbani andando in
prospettiva a risolvere anche il
problema ben più grave degli scarti che
provengono dalle aziende produttive che
si chiamano rifiuti speciali che cosa
rimane sullo stomaco del sistema di
gestione dei rifiuti rimangono i
prodotti non riciclabili e non
compostabili questi sono i dieci passi
gli ho capannori dirigo il centro di
ricerca rifiuti zero che banalmente va
aprire il sacco grigio per studiare cosa
c'è dentro
cosa rimane dopo la 80 per cento di
raccolta differenziata
quello è un errore di progettazione
perché non ha alternativa allo
smaltimento
e allora siccome la cabina di regia del
progetto rifiuti zero prevede che i
cittadini ne facciano parte con le loro
due mani ben in estate al cervello ne
facciano parte decisori politici che in
grado di fornire servizi efficaci ed
efficienti in modo tale di intercettare
materiali sempre meno sporchi e sempre
più merceologicamente importanti ma
occorre coinvolgere anche il produttore
questo passaggio
l'ottavo passo è topico nella strategia
rifiuti zero
si chiama coinvolgimento della
responsabilità estesa del produttore to
cortesemente dacci una mano noi abbiamo
risolto l'ottanta per cento del problema
ridisegna quei prodotti che ad oggi non
hanno alternativa allo smaltimento e che
sono un evidente errore di progettazione
industriale
il nostro modello è il cono gelato si
mangia la crema ma poi si mangia anche
il comm
non ci devono rimanere rifiuti ci si può
andare
rifiuti zero non è domani ma chi è
partito come a capannori nel mio comune
nel 2007 ci sta arrivando dannatamente
vicino che parte oggi ad alessandria nel
2030 ci arriverà maledettamente vicina e
qualcuno potrebbe dire ma e per quel 20
per cento che rimane non ci dobbiamo
rassegnare a impianti di industria
sporca inceneritori discariche
attraverso un sistema industriale già
ampiamente disponibile su scala
nazionale e internazionale si strappano
dalle grinfie dello smaltimento i
metalli e materiali cellulosici ancorché
parzialmente sporchi quei pezzi di vetro
che sono sfuggiti dalle maglie strette
delle raccolte differenziate porta a
porta a finire in discariche che non
somigliano assolutamente alle discariche
puzzolenti del presente del passato non
ci sarà più di quel 10 per cento che è
entrato nel sistema di gestione dei
materiali di scarto
si vabbè ma tutto questo dove sta
accadendo
domanda legittima viva lo scetticismo
certo ci sono moltissime esperienze su
scala nazionale e su scala
internazionale dalle quali occorre solo
copiate ma io stesso non è che venga da
marte
vengo dalla provincia di lucca nel 97
volevano realizzare due inceneritori uno
dei quali a capannoli nel mio comune
gliel'abbiamo impedito legando
strettamente alle comunità e adesso
capannone la provincia di lucca sono
all'avanguardia 330 mila abitanti ormai
rasentano il 75 per cento di raccolta
differenziata
che dire poi il treviso noi spesso siamo
famosi all'estero per le cattive
pratiche ma noi siamo anche come in un
paese delle montagne russe bravi di
buone pratiche
treviso è la miglior buona pratica
industriale le gestioni di materiali di
scarto all 85 e oltre di raccolta
differenziata nella baia di san
francisco tra san francisco berkeley 3
milioni di abitanti si sottrae oltre
l'ottanta per cento dallo smaltimento in
italia 250 comuni 6 milioni di abitanti
non parlano di rifiuti zero ma giorno
per giorno sono impegnate attraverso la
delibera rifiuti zero rifiuti zero si
può fare su quello che rimane abbiamo
detto bisogna un po anche ironizzare su
quello che non è riciclabile
allora abbiamo realizzato il piccolo
museo degli orrori di progettazione e
abbiamo censito 24 prodotti non
riciclabili non compostabili pannolini
usa e getta pannoloni assorbenti
femminili accendini usa e getta
le capsule le cialde monoporzione te per
il caffè le schede plastiche le abbiamo
messe idealmente in modo costruttivo
positivo propositivo nelle mani dei
produttori perché qualcosa cambi sul
serio
i risultati sono venuti la mia una
storia del paolo ii io quando sono
tornato dagli stati uniti dopo aver
ricevuto una telefonata nel mezzo della
mia classe che mi informava di aver
vinto il goldman price nel 2013
ho avuto è come se fossero rimbombate le
parole del mahatma gandhi all'inizio ti
sbeffeggio ranno ottenere ranno andrai
avanti ti attaccheranno duramente ea
volte ti criminalizzano vincerai saranno
tutti con te bene dopo che ho ricevuto
il premio
francisco dopo che sono stato ricevuto
alla casa bianca nel mitico studio ovale
e dal presidente obama
quando sono tornato in italia ho
percepito che rifiuti zero non è per una
ristretta nicchia non è presi gati e
trendy e fashion è figo si può fare
si può fare noi siamo come delle gocce
se ogni goccia sta per conto proprio
la goccia evapora ma se le gocce si
mettono insieme noi formiamo un oceano è
l'oceano del cambiamento bellezza e ai
giovani bisogna insegnare a vedere il
mare che è nella doccia
bisogna insegnare che ci si può
impegnare divertendosi
si deve insegnare loro che devono
continuare a sognare pur sapendo di
sognare
bisogna insegnare loro ea tutti noi che
di fronte alla crisi ambientale globale
che pulsa le porte delle comunità locali
il messaggio è chiaro o vinciamo tutti o
perdiamo tutti
e allora pop e drammatizzeranno
provocatoriamente gradevole e incisivo
il messaggio make love not waste fate
l'amore non fate rifiuti
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]